récord de casos de kobe 19 alarma las
autoridades de tokio los gobernantes
alertaron sobre un aumento de contagios
que sólo este jueves llegó a más de 3800
casos pero aseguran que este auge no
tiene nada que ver con los juegos
olímpicos debido a la burbuja creada en
torno a este evento a pesar de ello las
autoridades de la capital indicaron este
jueves que dos deportistas olímpicos
están contagiados por kobe 19 y 38 están
aislados en hoteles designados en la
ciudad
la gobernadora de tokio yuriko koike
instó a los organizadores a asegurarse
de no colocar una carga excesiva sobre
los hospitales de la capital
esta variante altamente contagiosa del
está está progresando para evitar el
número de nuevos casos hablamos de la
importancia de reducir el movimiento de
personas llegando a los números del
anterior estado de emergencia
según el ministerio de salud japonés el
país ha mantenido sus cifras de casos y
muertes por debajo de muchos otros
países pero su media de la última semana
ha subido y ahora es de 28 por cada
en mil habitantes en todo el territorio
y de 88 en tokio ante este repunte de
casos manifestantes en tokio piden
cancelar los juegos es contradictorio
ser anfitrión de las olimpiadas y tratar
de prevenir contagios de cody porque las
olimpiadas causaron que el público se
relaje está mal que el gobierno envíe
esos mensajes y luego ponga la
responsabilidad de prevenir el contagio
en el individuo entre las medidas
tomadas de este jueves se decidió
prolongar el estado de emergencia en
prefecturas como la de tokio y okinawa y
ahora las autoridades se están
planteando declararlo en cuatro
prefecturas más